hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round nine of the
magnus carlson invitational
preliminaries it's a yanni palmichu vs
magnus carlson
uh so the gentleman that's leading the
current candidates tournament against
the world champion and also uh jan is uh
the only person in the world that has a
positive score against magnus carlsen in
classical chess i think it's uh
uh in wins i think it's uh four wins for
for nepo and only one for magnus
could be two now i don't i don't really
uh recall but uh
definitely quite a feat so it could be
problematic for magnus if uh
nepo turns out the winner of the
candidates tournament but
this is rapid chess here the rules are
different and
uh uh well let's just see what happens
here as it's a very interesting game
so nipple with the white pieces opens
with e4
uh we have c5 by magnus of course he
goes for his sicilian
uh we have knight to f3 knight to c6 and
d4 now
and this will be a very very long
theoretical struggle c captures knight
captures
uh we have knight to f6 and the knight
to c3 and here of course
e5 going for the alaska variation or the
pelican or
uh you know whatever you want to call it
knight
d to b5 and now comes d6 so
yeah this is nothing new we have bishop
to g5 preparing knight to d5
and the black kicks away the knight so
a6 uh
knights the a3 and now b5 preparing b4
so of course white gets the knight in
the center of the board we have knight
to d5
and bishop to e7 now not allowing this
pin to exist we have bishop captures
bishop captures and
c3 now so like i said this has all been
played before
thousands of times uh and here at
knights to e7 uh magnus offers a trade
of another pair of knights
uh castles is the move that has been
played the most here but knight
the e7 is the modern tri the the this is
a
kind of a 20 21 uh move so here we have
knight captures on f6
g captures uh as often uh in these lines
of the sicilian
it's perfectly fine to capture with this
because later on you're going to have f5
and you're going to put more pressure on
white
center which which will of course uh
improve your own center
so knight to c2 the knight now needs to
come back to the game and now
bishop to b7 putting pressure on the e4
pawn we have bishop to d3
defending and now d5 the
sicilian dream has been achieved we have
queen to e2 preparing to castle
and now f5 and now there's a lot of
pressure here but
like i said this has all been played
before so here in nepal just castle's
queen side
uh we have f captures on e4 and now
bishop captures an e4 making it
impossible to capture the bishop because
the queen is still on d8
so queen to c7 getting the queen out of
the way and now
bishop to f3 also doing the same with
the bishop we have queen side castles
for black as well
and now g3 the g2 pawn will not remain a
target and also you want to
have the g2 square available for your
bishop if black starts with some e4
pushes
and here there is one game in the
database where f5 was played but here we
have king to b8 by magnus
and it is only now as of move 19 that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how nipple deals with this
king to b1
uh also a nice prophylactic move and now
you don't want your king on c1 if
something like b4 or d4 happens in the
future
you will have to capture open up the the
c file uh definitely makes sense to get
the king away from there we have knight
the c8 and the knight now also needs to
get back into the game probably coming
to c4 at some point uh
or via the the b6 square uh we have rook
h to e1
preparing to capture the pawn here and
the magnus defense at rook h to e8 we
have knight to e3
now with a triple attack on the d5 pawn
and knight to b6 now defending the d5
pawn one more time we have queen back to
c2
trying to activate the queen queen to f5
is an idea also the h7 pawn is hanging
so nepotil
needs to deal with that as well uh and
he plays f6
uh strengthens the center but also now
the queen guards the h7 pawn
uh magnus uh not nipple we have bishop
to g2
and now uh rook to d6 magnus prepares to
double up rooks and the d
file we have rook to d2 nepo does the
same and rook
e to d8 with rook e to d1 now again
everything's about the the d file now uh
and here while you could go
knight to c4 right away and go for
something like this
get a nice semi-open b file and you will
have
a lot of pressure in the center magnus
first improves the position with a5 he
wants to get those pawns as far as
possible
uh before playing such a committal move
so here a3 and only now
knight to c4 we have captures on c4
b captures on c4 and now uh queen to f5
nepal wants to
uh keep the queen very active here uh we
have
king to a7 uh and now king to a1 so both
players uh getting the king to uh
to the safest place possible uh we have
queen to d7 magnus offers a queen trade
and here nepo declines with
queen to h5 uh we have queen back to c7
by magnus
waiting to see what nepo will do and
here nepo goes f4
now if you don't do this you could run
into some very unpleasant
d4 ideas uh so best just uh
go at it right away so f4 here and now
uh
e4 by magnus uh so the d4 square is very
nicely protected now and you will not be
able to push that pawn all that easily
so rook to d4 uh and now bishop to c6
uh we have rook one to d2 getting
another defender to the b2 pawn
uh because it moves like queen to b6
rook to b8 attacking the b
pawn are are definitely coming so here
we have bishop to e8 chasing back
nipples queen
queen back to e2 and now bishop back to
c6
uh we have queen to e3 by nipple and the
queen to b6 now
uh preparing to put some pressure along
the the b file and the b2 pawn
uh with f5 now preparing ideas like g4
h4 and the g5
and now rook uh 6 is coming back to d7
so now you wanna double rooks and the b
file uh we have queen to h6 now going
after the f6
pawn and now bishop to a4 the bishop is
very nicely placed here also the queen
now defends the f6
pawn so g4 the plan is as we said
pushing the pawns here creating some
past pawns uh and
king the a6 now again uh a safer square
for
for the king we have bishop to f1 now
aligning the bishop with the king
so you have to be a little bit careful
here and magnus says okay maybe the
queen
the king is not all that safe now here
so king back to a7
and nepo continues with his plan on the
king side with
h4 preparing g5 and now rook to b7
finally magnus will triple up on the on
the b
file we have queen back to e3 now
aligning the queen again with the king
so you again have to be very careful
with what you're doing here and now rook
uh
d to b8 now with the triple battery here
there's a lot of pressure on the b2 pawn
luckily
uh it's uh rook rook queen not uh for
example
rook queen rook so the rook is a
sufficient defender here
so g5 nepal continues with his plan of
creating a pawn here
and now bishop back to d7 challenging
the f5 pawn now that that is undefended
we have g
captures on f6 and now bishop captures
on f5
and now nipple definitely has a pass
pawn here on f6
but uh for the moment it seems to be
hanging but not really because
we can't forget that the queen is still
aligned with the king even though
uh there is a queen and rook in between
because if you capture
uh uh this uh after bishop captures on
f5
if you go for this it's going to be well
it's going to be very scary so here
first we have queen to g5
not allowing this not not allowing this
but
uh just getting the the queen here uh
with tempo attacking the bishop also the
f6 pawn is now nicely defended
and now bishop back to e6 uh with
bishop captures on c4 and this is the
position from the thumbnail
uh because uh this move definitely makes
sense
because if bishop captures on c4 uh
works then it's game over for magnus if
it doesn't
then it doesn't uh nipple was convinced
that it doesn't he played bishop
captures on c4
but now feel free to pause the video and
win this game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds as
there is one little thing that that
nipple missed
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
spotting the idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook the g8 this is the only move
that wins and magnus found it rather
rather quickly uh the point is if you
accept the bishop then you get this rook
to d6 move and then it's just game over
the queen is under attack the bishop is
under attack and
you cannot move the queen away from the
defense of the a5 pawn because queen
captures on a5 is just deadly
so here you have to keep an eye on the
pawn then you just lose this bishop and
then
your entire position just crumbles there
really is no playing this
uh so that that's what nepal had in mind
however after bishop captures on c4
rook to g8 was played by magnus and now
it's uh
it's a bit of a different story uh
because now uh the queen has to move
queen to e5 and okay it seems like the
idea is still uh the same but now
rook to g1 with check uh we have king
the a2 you cannot block with the rook
because then you're no longer defending
the b2 pawn so here after rook g1 check
king to a2 and now comes d captures on
c4
now it's possible because now if you
move the rook a rook to d6
queen to b3 is checkmate so after d
captures on c4 we have b4
you have to play this there's no other
way to prolong the game
uh so you have to defend like this uh
but now
c captures on b3 with check uh with a
nice uh ambassador capture
uh so uh the bishop guards that you have
to move the queen
and rook also guard it so look back to a
king back to b2
and now there is a really really
spectacular move here
that you can play so uh for the second
time uh
pause the video and win the game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
spectacular
rook to a1 uh also for those who just
want to enjoy the show but
this is not what magnus played rook to
a1 is just
deadly because uh well rook to a2
is coming and of course if you capture
the rook then it's the very simple
beat you check uh king to b1 and bishop
to a2 again with check you sacrifice the
second piece
and then uh b1 is checkmate so this is
what was in the position
uh magnus however decided to improve the
position a little bit he played a three
e3 first put pressure on the rook but
now he gives
nipple one little moment where he can
save the game
so for the third time pause the video
here and save the game for nepo
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not losing the game and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show uh it's
rook to a4 this is the only move that
saves the game because now you're
threatening
rook captures on a5 and the king will
not be able to go to b8 because the
queen covers that square so here
uh there really is no good way to
continue for black if you try defending
this
let's say king here then you get rook to
d6
and then you just uh blunder your queen
but okay luckily as the b3 pawn is
defended you you can go for a perpetual
with rook to g to check king b1
rook g1 check king b2 and then again
repeating this uh
to infinity and it will be a draw by
threefold repetition
however nepal did not find this after
carlson's e3
nipple captured it with queen captures
on e3 but now only now
magnus finds the move that you guys saw
on the previous move so here
rook the a1 and now nipple saw that
there really isn't much you can do
if if you capture then it's the same
idea that we've already shown bishop a
to check king c
king c2 and then uh just b1 for example
will be checkmate
so instead after rook day one queen to
e5 was played
yeah but it's not much better now comes
rook to a to check
king to b1 and rook captures on d2 we
have rook captures on d2 and here
b2 uh and now there really isn't
all that all that much you can do here
uh so after this uh
after this b2 move uh uh
it was uh in this position basically
that yani pony should resign to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
bishop to a to check is just deadly
and there's no way to to defend against
this you cannot capture it's defended
twice there's no way to prolong the game
and that's just it there's there's not
even a useful move that you could try
here to
to even you know pose some problems
so after b2 uh uh nipple resigned the
game and a wonderful victory for magnus
carlsen in round nine of this um
uh preliminary series uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it and congratulations special
congratulations to everyone
who found all three pause the video
moments because the
you know these moves were not easy to
find uh so
uh also uh as usual uh i i would like to
thank
quank peter dang uh corey talleybunk
cloudchess.com henry alma and scott
melis for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the uh tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day